[Music]  we'll have it I had a heart attack I had  to get a transplant does it feel any  different  can you tell it's someone else's I just  want everything to go back to the way it  was before it's just so weird that  someone had to die in order for me to  live noria fridge  thank you both your daughter she saved  Sasha's life I can't even begin  imagining what you all have been going  through I just want you to know that  we're gonna do everything we can to keep  her memory alive Nancy and I have  endowed a scholarship in Becky's name we  want to offer the scholarship to Sasha  watch out for that family you've seen  things things that she saw this is  kidding  [Music]  I think that one day we're gonna look  back and realize that's this whole heart  attack thing was the best thing that  ever happened to you  [Music]  you